Paris jeudi 25 juillet 2019
la canicule est sur le point de
s'intensifier raison pour laquelle la
vigilance a encore été étendu
il est 15h20 le mercure affiche
42,4° à l'ombre dans les rues de la
capitale une température jamais atteinte
pulvérisante le record historique de
1947 la canicule de 2019 a été
exceptionnelle par son intensité en
France parce que 42 degrés à Paris c'est
encore une vraie question en plus entre
la température ressentie et la
température réelle le manque d'air
surtout voilà je vais surtout rentrer
chez moi fermer toutes les fenêtres et
puis sortir on n'est pas habitué à ces
températures là surtout qu'à Paris enfin
en tout cas dans les grandes villes on
parle d'îlots de chaleur c'est lié au
bitume lié au fait que les immeubles
sont sont très collés les uns aux autres
donc comment on vit quand on subit une
canicule on recherche des points d'eau
on va vers des fontaines
et elle arrive plus du tout à boire de
l'eau bon écoutez je
vous envoie
on a eu un été où les gens ont compris
ce qui était changement climatiques le
Français a compris parce que ça ne se
passe plus à l'autre bout de la planète
parce que c'est plus le Groenland ou le
Canada qui va être directement concerné
ou bien on va plus parler uniquement des
ours on va parler du Parisien qui a
chaud on va parler du gardois qui qui va
vivre avec 46 degrés donc c'est vraiment
un basculement dans les mentalités
[Musique]
on voit très bien que il faut s'adapter
obligatoirement parce que ça va
s'accélérer
en effet cette canicule que nous
pensions exceptionnelle pourrait bien
faire partie demain de notre quotidien
on va sans doute subir de plus en plus
de canicule comme ça aussi sévère elle
pourrait intervenir pratiquement tous
les ans en France et surtout de durer
plus longtemps là on a eu le point de
température on s'était dur pendant 4-5
jours puis après on est retombé si ça
dure 15 jours 3 semaines un mois
des canicules beaucoup plus longues qui
pourraient donc avoir des répercussions
dramatiques sur notre santé l'être
humain doit avoir une température
constante à 37 degrés ce qu'on appelle
l'homéostasie quand vous avez une
température extérieure extrêmement
importante ben en attendant ça avoir une
température qui a du mal à se réguler
[Musique]
et si ça dure la nuit on n'a pas de
moyens de recharger de diminuer cette
température et donc du coup c'est 37
degrés sont de plus en plus difficiles à
maintenir
subir des canicules c'est pas bon pour
la santé c'est pas bon pour le corps
donc si on ne le subir régulièrement il
y aura des conséquences sanitaires c'est
sûr en France
le nombre de décès pourrait être
multiplié par 30 ou 40 d'effacer sans
lui régulièrement chaque année et la
quasi-totalité de ses décès serait ni
aux canicule
vous y passerez
non seulement les canicules seront plus
récurrentes plus longues mais elles
seront aussi beaucoup plus chaudes
car si en 100 ans la température sur
Terre a augmenté d'un degré elle
pourrait bien grimper de manière
fulgurante dans les prochaines années
c'est pas linéaire du tout ou petit à
petit on va gagner un dixième de degré
tous les 10 ans non ça s'accélère en
plus si on continue à agir comme on l'a
dit aujourd'hui si on continue à émettre
autant de gaz à effet de cirque
aujourd'hui d'ici la fin du siècle la
température pour monter de 6 à 7 degrés
ce qui est énorme
si on va cette nuit degrés je dirais
plus c'est plus un changement climatique
c'est un cataclysme c'est ça qu'il faut
que les gens réalisent on va voir le
climat de l'Afrique qui va remonter
jusqu'à jusqu'au latitude nord là c'est
un sacré un sacré sacré bouleversement
[Musique]
il a peut-être falloir se mettre à vivre
en mode espagnol avec plus de phase de
sieste
on travaille très tôt le matin peut-être
manger plus tard peut-être vivre plus
tard le soir et décaler notre journée
c'est des vrais questions qu'on doit se
poser et que les sociétés en fait vont
être amenées à vivre au quotidien et à
se poser de plus en plus
[Musique]
dans les années à venir nous serons donc
forcés de trouver des solutions contre
la chaleur et ce pour protéger notre
santé
[Musique]